COMMITTEE FOR THIRTY JUNE
FOURTEENTH.
CHEN MICHAEL ORDER.
FISHY ADVICE AND AUTOMATED
ACCORDING TO TODAY'S MAY JUST BE
MADE AS ALSO BEING TELEVISED.
BAD SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GOING HERE CUNNINGHAM HERE
CARILLO HERE AROUND HERE.
FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
GRAYSON MAN'S NAZARIAN.
SALAS.
WALDRON CAN HAVE.
WE HAVE A CORPSMAN WE HAVE
CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR MOTION
LIKE SENATE JOB.
I THINK MOVED BY MISTER NAZARIAN
SAN ANDREAS CARILLO --
MAD SURCHARGES CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HIGH COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
CARILLO.
AYE CARILLO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I GRAYSON MAYES NOSE
AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE SALAS SALAS AYE
WALDRON.
BUT THE MOST IS PASS AND THE
SCHOOLS BECAUSE IT TURNED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
RENDON